hello and a very warm welcome to the
part two of the data flow medium I hope
you like part one of the illustration
where we add is one of the most
intriguing NLP come ml applications
called word clustering by achieving it
in a data processing pipeline if you
haven't already please do check it out
there we use dataflow ml in order to
handle PC and secular models
sequentially as already promised we'll
visualize the P collections obtained in
part 1. we'll also export the entire
pipeline as a data future hope you find
this demo interesting as well now let's
move ahead with the dip this interactive
beam Jupiter lab extension interactively
inspects the state of pipelines and data
associated with each P collection this
extension can be manually installed as
well more details in the description
below
now click on the interactive beam tab
click on open inspector and select the
kernel for your notebook
so fetch words indicate the process of
extraction of the words from the CSV
file
then these are passed through the Run
inference PC operation in order to
generate their 300 dimensional word
impedance
then run inference circuit learn comes
into picture for clustering these 300
dimensional vectors for each and every
single word
finally these clusters are reported
visualized and analyzed if I click on
specie dfp collection
and check the box corresponding to
visualize and facets and click on apply
I can see all the 196 circles which are
indicating the words taken into
consideration for the testing purpose
clicking on any one of them tells you
the word it actually contains now let's
click on pcdf1p collection in order to
visualize 300 dimensional vectors
so these circles contain the first value
of each 300 dimensional Vector created
for 196 entries
various statistical parameters such as
being standard deviation median and
minimum and Max values are also computed
at last let's click on scikit-learn dfp
collection
and this will indicate all the cluster
assignment
so if I set the label by as inference we
can easily observe the cluster
assignment
if I set the x axis is inference we can
visualize how many words are assigned to
Cluster 0 to 1 and 3.
similarly you can also set y-axis
bidding as inference
and have a lot of fun trying out
different options and visualize the
changes in the output
if I set the color by as example
and click on any one of the circle it
indicates the vector corresponding to
that particular Circle
and if I visit this pcdfp collection
again
you can see that the corner Circle
actually corresponds to the word Google
which is assign cluster 2 for Tech
let's get back to the notebook as
already mentioned all of these
visualizations could be generated
through Apache be metric to be module as
well we can easily observe how
convenient it was to use the interactive
beam tab over the programmatic approach
when you want to control the parameters
like window size Etc
will Now launch a data flow ml job from
the clustering pipeline we just built as
is customary let's start with all the
necessary inputs
here we set up the required pipeline
options and gcp project
the command GS util MB creates a
standard class multi-regional us bucket
also we specify the region the GCS
staging location and a temporary
location for cloud data flow tool
then we can specify the directory to
store the output files of the job
by executing the below code snippet we
can see our data flow job up and running
in the gcp console now click on this
link
here we can observe the data flow
pipeline graphically and in tabular
format as well congrats you did it
clicking on each step mentions you its
details such as status stages and input
steps
if we get back to the graph view you can
click on the drop down arrow on each of
the blocks if you click on fetch words
it tells you it's a read operation
as of now we can see that none of the
stages have succeeded
these words are written to a file in the
cloud storage
block consists of two operations
including beamable run inference
similarly run a field scikit and block
also contains two stages which are yet
to succeed
this is a print clusters block
responsible for displaying all the
resultant clusters
this time instead of words the inference
results in the form of vectors and
clusters are written to the file in the
cloud storage
if I click on execution details
and Stage workflow the execution stages
of this data flow ml job are represented
in the form of workflow graph if I click
on worker progress we see that no graph
is available as of now since none of
these stages has succeeded till now
we finally see some stages getting
succeeded if any error occurs by the
data flow job runs it can be checked
under the log section for
troubleshooting
it's super awesome to see all the stages
successful in the data flow by play
if I get back to the tabular view all
the status are complete successfully
this is stage workflow diagram
indicating completion of all stages now
if I click on worker progress
we can see the worker details such as
work attempt ID and its duration
under the job Matrix section
we can check CPU and memory utilization
as well as throughput
now we'll run some commands to access
Google Cloud Storage from The Notebook
itself from the command line you can
access cloud storage through GS util a
python application you can verify the
directory and the file content by
executing the following commands
three folders namely output staging and
temp are created inside the folder demo
we have performed right operation to the
two dot txt files placed inside the
output folder
if I display the content of all of the
files in this particular directory
it shows all the infinite results as
well as the words
if I get back to the gcp console click
on cloud storage and buckets I could see
there is a bucket with the name data
flow ml bucket AA demo we'll click on it
click on demo folder we'll verify the
content of each and every single folder
starting with temp
followed by staging
and most importantly output we are able
to see two files with all the details
we'll click on the file if I click on
the authenticated URL for the file I'll
be easily able to check its contents
the similar argument holds true for the
first file as well
and there it is we can see the file
populated with inference results
and this thumbs up our work on the gcp
console
let me get back to the notebook again
and if we revisit the graph generated by
the Apache beam interactive B module so
we can easily see that all the Run
inference operations are occurring in a
sequence but if I rerun this code
so if You observe there are two changes
the right operations to the cloud
storage also do occur in the pipeline
this is the consequence of the export of
this pipeline as a data flow job enjoy
exploring and playing around with other
options that the console hasn't built
for you the link for the Google Cloud
medium blog with all the code Snippets
is mentioned in the description below
let's recapitulate what we learned we
understood the importance of word
clustering in real life use case
scenarios we got to see how powerful
data flow mm is for building scalable
pipelines for handling ml model
sequentially and last but not the least
NLP and ml capabilities are powerful
libraries like PC and scikit learn and
fitness discipline should you require
more details or specifics regarding what
is discussed refer to these documents
towards my left hand side we hope you
found it informative and useful for any
further comments or queries please feel
free to reach out till then thank you
bye viewers and see you soon with
another video